I'm not what you think I am
[Music]
Captain Marvel is the totally rad 90
superhero movie introducing us to Carol
Danvers for the first time in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's out March 8th
starring brie Larson but reviews are out
right now this is gonna be a
non-spoilery one but we're also gonna do
a spoiler e1 on Friday so you don't have
to worry right now and joining me for
this all ladies discussion is angelique
Jackson thanks for having me in a bomber
Jack yes we had to address appropriately
we have to be an homage to miss Carol
Danvers can I say I am an homage to
goose the cat okay let's get into
everything let's deep dive what were
your initial thoughts leaving the
theater before we get into the
nitty-gritty here so when I walked out
of that theater I was fully pumped I was
all higher further faster I just I loved
Carol Danvers I'm actually really into
her as a character and I'm into the
vibes of this movie gave me their
friendship I I think this is a good
addition to the MCU do I think it's best
picture no do I think it's probably the
best MCU movie maybe not but it's a good
one I think Carol is probably my
favorite MCU character that that I've
related to on that level like I love
Valkyrie so much I love the wasp so much
but there was something about like her
dry sense of humor and her wit and just
like her stubbornness which I really
really have like everyone behind the
cameras like yeah but I just related to
on such like a personal level and it was
just like so 90s centric which I
obviously if I go so well I had a smile
on my face from start to finish and I
loved how linear it was like it didn't
bounce around between all these plots
and a lot of times when when we're
getting an origin story I hate to say
this I kind of dread it yeah because I'm
like there's gonna be this low and this
like a low point and that doesn't really
happen in this movie no not at all
because like you were saying with the
way they tell this story they try and go
into like figuring out who Carol is yeah
by these like flashbacks and in that
like yeah you're getting more of the
detail about who she is but instead of
it being like oh she's a nobody with no
powers not interesting and then
becomes this big superhero it's like
nope she starts out with her powers she
already is this established you know
superhero to some extent she's really
just a super soldier right and then she
becomes a superhero so it's really that
evolution versus just you know yeah it
kind of goes like the back 2/3 and then
and then fills in the rest along the way
which I really I really really enjoy she
just feels like the first human eye and
I know you know she's a cream or e'er
but I know what you mean yeah the first
like human woman like I don't really
relate to black widow I'm not a super
spy but I am a person that could have
become a fighter pilot that maybe could
have become a superhero she just has
this very grounded element I think a lot
of that is due to Brees portrayal of her
I think she finds the humanity in this
character in a very real way and that's
just like the basis of who she is she's
she's sassy she's brassy she's you know
smart she's very talented and it's just
very organic people were asking about
the humor and this movie overall because
I like her sense of humor in the movie a
lot what I like about this one though it
it it has like a dry dry wit to it
that's a yes or no question yes at the
other movies every movie finds their own
kind of humor and their own style and
this one is something different yeah the
only complaint I had about this movie
was that it for me took a while to like
land on that tone because when in the
early parts of the movie which can be
confusing sometimes she does start out
as a Cree soldier she's on hala her
humor is like completely not understood
by anybody and janna planet so it kind
of me is like off-putting to the
audience cuz you're like oh is she funny
or she's not funny because no one's ever
laughing but when we get to earth you
actually understand oh no they just
don't like that earth people yeah they
don't get her earth humor and and it
actually ends up working really well
especially when she and Sam Jackson get
together their chemistry is just through
the roof they are really good friends if
this is our third time working together
and it shows they their chemistry is
just insane and in this whole press tour
you see them as a duo they're doing
interviews together and I'm going and
expecting just this to be Carole's solo
mission but she really is in tandem with
Sam Jackson with Nick Fury I guess I
could say him
this entire film but and I loved them as
a
totally it's nice that it's it's kind of
a dual origin story you get to figure
out how Nick Fury became Nick Fury at
the same time as you're figuring out why
Captain Marvel was someone so important
that he needed to call at the end of
infinity war yeah and just to touch on
the D aging effects in this movie it's
been off-putting to me in the past where
I know I am watching like ad aged actor
with like I don't know it feels like a
deep fake to me sometimes watching this
home I felt like I was watching 90s 90
95 Sam Jackson totally no problem and
what was great about it too and I don't
know if it's the technology or what but
you can see that the de-aging effect
itself just worked because both Sam
Jackson and Clark Craig as Agent Coulson
ther D aging was equally good yeah so
they both just looked like you know this
wouldn't have happened and actually came
out in 1995 which is really really well
done the whole entire look of the movie
just in general captured that 90s look
very well and not in a way that felt
like it was too much of a throwback it
just felt like oh no we just seemed
completely nailed the production yeah I
have I have minor criticisms and one
being I am a sucker for nostalgia like I
love 90s nostalgia I am weak what it
comes to it it worked on me yeah but
there were moments where I was like this
is a little over the times there's a few
lines that are a little you know a
little lame yeah there's some deep deep
nineties references that you're like
okay we didn't have to go that far I
loved a blockbuster the Paradiso
blockbuster was great because you know
movie lovers and Marvel fans are
basically the same so they all remember
going to the blockbuster and watching
any out yes exactly the main movie went
there for and then I have to rent scream
for the hundredth time I mean but I
would have probably been renting this
for the hundredth time too so it kind of
works out that's true can I complain
about one more thing it's my only other
complaints where the guy it's the one
thing that like bothered me a lot um she
had perfect beach waves the entire movie
like even during the fight scenes and it
drove me crazy it's problematic because
okay we had solved this with the wasp
she had pulled her hair back it wasn't
in like a high beautiful ariana Poe
it was just got normal Bologna back I'm
gonna fight she had just like just
beautiful like styled like this even mid
sequence being like I just closed the
hair out of her face in the train scene
you see that in the trailer so not a
spoiler at all but just the idea Carol
you know the Carol Danvers we see on
earth
she's a fighter pilot her hair is in a
bun it's the same length I don't
understand we have to marvel someone me
blowing in the wind the whole time yeah
I mean she looks great the memory she
couldn't get back was how to put her
hair in a ponytail I'm sorry but maybe
they don't have hair ties a lien on hala
because Minerva's hair is also like you
know it's shaved on one side but just
flowing down on the other oh well then
so maybe it's just a hair tie shortage
hmm [ __ ] need a target trophy bananas
it drove me bananas a lot of people were
asking and I'm curious your thoughts on
this does it feel like a late add or
some kind of retcon situation in the MCU
to have this story come up now given
that kind of hint that she's gonna be a
big deal in M game yeah well it is
interesting because when we were kind of
deep diving into where this fit into MCU
we were talking about how it does feel
like there's a bit of revisionist
history with where this shows up and
kind of explaining how certain things
came to be yeah even some of the like
Nick Fury's origin story the origin of
the Avengers kind of in general they
kind of touch on a lot of those things
in this movie but at the same time there
was a world where Captain Marvel or Miss
Marvel was actually written into the
early script for age of Ultron so this
character could have shown up earlier
they just made the decision that you
know they didn't think it made sense to
have her show up in the Avengers before
explaining who she was so I appreciate
that they made that choice because you
don't have Black Panther where they
introduced him in Civil War they kind of
explain a bit of who he is and what
Wakanda is but it's really black panther
where they introduce the entire world
right so I think that's why it works
that way you can introduce the character
and then broaden it out to the world I
do think if you introduce the character
and just had her like pop up and be like
I'm Kara wink like Brighton have been
as helpful as introducing this whole
character understanding why she's such a
big deal
understanding why Nick Fury would call
her the end of infinity war because
before that you're just like well who's
this it was like it's just another
character you now understand no she's
the strongest the most powerful he's
been waiting to call her until it really
mattered I I would say going into this
movie I felt a lot of that like I was
like why are they just now gonna
introduce Scrolls because that just sets
up a whole chain reaction of possible
scenarios and introducing her who's like
supposed to be this like you know I
guess one of the strongest effect
Barry's gonna call her at the end of
infinity war but I think the way that
they explain everything and like why
she's not around is executed really
really well and I think people are gonna
be satisfied with yeah I think it's just
one of those things you just have to
just accept it until you see the whole
movie and you're like oh okay yeah we
also don't know what she's gonna do an
end game like I think like people are
going in being like she's gonna be the
one that's gonna like go up to Thanos
and grab his fists and throw him into
space like no probably not know it's
still gonna be a team effort she's not
just coming in to be like move aside
guys I got this yeah in games like
captain a Captain Marvel - yeah um but
if they do set it up very well to me
just make sense as to why she was there
why she wasn't there um I am so curious
- if the reason why we didn't get those
girls yet was because of this whole like
Fox thing cuz Fox apparently oh we're
right right yeah
but if then you introduce them and then
it's like well who who's a scroll
yeah is that if you're anybody a scroll
well that's exact and that's actually
another interesting thing like okay well
now since this girl's can shape-shift
and turn into other people what does
that mean about you know what's gonna
move on an endgame
are we gonna see like Scrolls back on
earth like our are some of our heroes
scrolls now just like open the doors up
to more code it does it opens a whole
Pandora's box this is like my main geez
time travel and stars anyway
let's touch on some other characters
really quick because I are asking how is
ghost the cat house cues the cat I don't
wanna give anything away but goose the
cat is amazing goose account was nice I
have her I mean she got a sweater I have
a sweater there's a reason I have a
sweater let me just say
um goose cats Grey Goose cat is amazing
um let's let's hit that fun fact about
goosey cat though that is very important
to you Oh goose The Cat in the comics is
named chewy what's your name Terence
but in this one I think this by the
McCarroll is not actually ash in
disguise she did not actually star in
Captain Marvel even though it seems like
it's probably possible I'm us girl and
then palace
played by ben mendelsohn also amazing
there's a lot there's a lot to that
character that is really interesting and
ben mendelsohn should be cast in every
franchise ever absolutely honestly Ben
was the biggest surprise for me um I
didn't know a ton about the Scrolls
going in I always didn't know a ton
about Talos because the scrolls haven't
been involved in the MCU yet so he was
kind of the introduction for all of us
into this character you know he's the
big bad but he's also you know just so
brilliant in the way he executes this
character I'm using his natural accent
was a choice that they decided to use I
just thought it was he's just tries to
steal the show which is normally Sam
Jackson's role yeah and he manages to do
it so well I want to get into a bunch of
spoilers so will you stick around and do
another that's another video with me
okay so uh overall thoughts are we okay
with this Captain Marvel final thoughts
oh we are absolutely okay with this
Captain Marvel while it is a movie that
is going to make a bajillion dollars of
the box-office I know I said it's
probably not my best picture it's
something that you should go see I think
that it's coming out at International
Women's Day it's a big move forward for
Marvel having this first female lead
film and they don't really make that the
focus of the movie it's not the idea
that oh well she's so great because
she's a woman or she is so great in
spite of the fact that she's a woman
it's just a fact
Carole was a you know amazing fighter
pilot and then she becomes this amazing
superhero and that's all being a person
there there are some great moments as a
woman watching it where you can feel the
themes and you can feel the power and
especially there's a great female
friendship between Bree and leshawna
Lynch's characters who is Maria Rambo
yes we'll talk more about Maria and her
daughter in the next video but those
things in general
just make you feel powerful not just as
a woman but as a person and that's why I
think you really hit the nail on the
head with that entire spiel that was
amazing yes I'm gonna just
wholeheartedly agree with you and we're
gonna fact let us know what you guys
think about Captain Marvel when you see
it and of course come back for the
spoiler video because we're gonna get
into all those theories facts twists
turns all those things
ash Crossin where can we find you hi
Angelique eight one four on Twitter and
you can catch me sometimes when you
smile okay thanks guys so much for
watching
[Music]